I go through Page by Page
run page two page three this is at the
top page four and page five any matters
arising we've got a proposal for the
minutes councilor Benton and councilor
Hawkins second
um everyone four
against
abstentions three abstentions
okay
and public participation we actually do
have some members of the public wishing
to speak today I believe
who would like to go first
yeah
um do you want to come for uh there's a
speaker over there
thank you
thank you for taking the time to attend
um I'll remind you you've got three
minutes
um
so it's you can have three minutes each
lovely
um hi my name is Anna
um I am a service user at Biddeford Link
Center
I'm also part of friends of the North
Island centers
um I'm here today basically to ask you
guys to help support us in keeping them
um as you may be well aware Devon County
Council had put forward a proposal to
close the link centers including the one
in Biddeford
um the only problem is is that the
consultation itself is based on
information where they won't say where
they got from and I believe and many
others believe it's false
um they for example they say on it it's
just a drop in from mild mental health
and that on its own is an either full
ignorance or a full lie and most people
who attend
um benefit links Link Center at least
have what's classified as severe mental
health illnesses others are moderate
none of them will be classified as mild
mental health
um
DCC also wanted to try and get away from
the building's based model however it's
been successful for over 30 years and
it's also supporting people with
long-term most quite often lifelong
mental health illnesses and it continues
to support people to prevent escalation
to
higher risks and higher
a higher level intervention like Crisis
level and hospitalization and even being
referred back to the Community Mental
Health Team
um
DCC seem to think that it's only just a
drop in but it's only a drop in because
ever since lockdown when it was reopened
instead of having it opened as it was
pre-lockdown as a mental health Hub with
group activity therapeutic activities
and the staff running those things
um
it's because the staff have been not
allowed to run any groups so at the
moment it is effectively dropping but we
do our own therapeutic stuff there but
it's not engaging people
um so we wanted DCC to reopen it as it
was before but they haven't done that
they're trying to shut them down but at
the long in the long term it will
actually cost the councils a lot more
money per person for trying to do it to
do these little private ones or little
separate ones all it is to keep it in
the link center under the NHS most of
these other Provisions that they
supposedly have is not for people with
anything more severe than mild mental
health like the Burton art gallery drop
in that's not suitable for people at the
link center and things like Talk Works
um doesn't work for people at the link
center because we're too complex Etc
thanks so much thank you for speaking
um I do like to speak okay
I'm sorry yeah
um I'm also a service user at the link
centers
I wanted to speak to you today to let
you know on a personal level how much I
rely on the link centers
and how important they are
I've suffered from mental health from a
young age and Trauma has been a Cause
um beautiful unforeseen circumstances
I've got
a lot of personal pressures at the
moment which are overwhelming
um
and I don't know how to cope with them
without the one-on-ones one-to-one
support I get from the staff at centers
I also get peer support there
and it's all
in one place I don't have to go
Here There and Everywhere I don't have
to repeat
my stories because they know
they help me stay safe
and more importantly they helped me stay
alive
I'd like to ask the council to support
us
to do whatever we can to save these
centers
because I can't guarantee my safety
and I'm sure there's other service users
that can't
thank you
can't guarantee their safety without
them
so everything
I think he did that was really he did
really well thank you
much for coming and on behalf of the
whole committee you've made a very good
case and we're glad to hear it
um I suppose I'd like to say I totally
support the idea that this link center
should be reopened properly
we all know that the reason why it's
being closed is not for these spurious
um consultation results which you
brought up and questioned but because
Devon County Council is short of money
but the fact of the matter is that I do
believe that Mental Health Services are
vital to our community
and Biddeford at the moment is being
stripped of its services is being
denuded of its public services for
people this is a low-wage poor economy
area most people can't afford to pay for
any private therapy and as somebody who
worked in the link center a long time
ago when it was probably in its Heyday
as a project worker for a volunteer
befriending service for people with
mental health services I know it was a
very friendly relaxed therapeutic place
for people to come to they could not
only get the therapy they needed but
they could actually do things that relax
them there was ah there there was plenty
of other creative materials so that
people could actually benefit and
improve their whole personal psyche and
that's just been taken away and it's
just so short-sighted I completely agree
with you this is a totally stupid
short-sighted decision that's been made
and it will cause more problems than any
money ever saves so I do hope that
between us as a committee we can get
together and either have a motion to
full Council or although I know that we
have been supportive up to now anyway to
a certain extent but in a much stronger
way to make sure that we can get the
link center properly reopened for the
people of Biddeford who need it yeah um
completely agree and we brought it up in
Urgent matters at the last meeting
um via councilor craigie and we voted
unanimously then to invite someone in
from Devon County Council to this
meeting that should have been today but
they declined they said that they
couldn't attend a certain date so we
asked them to come on a different date
and they said actually no they weren't
going to attend at all so it is
something that we've raised at the
committee and feel really strongly about
and yeah we're behind you and anything
we can do we've been in contact with
councilor Hudson who's our
representative from torridge who attends
the meetings at County Hall and she
we'll make sure that she hears what you
said today and she will be representing
us on those decisions that are taking
place and they did come back to us to
say that the consultation had been
extended
um
[Music]
yeah at this time
okay thank you I'll make sure that um
Karen can me follow that up and find out
what exactly what's going on with it
um councilor craigie it's not on the
agenda so you can't really debate as
such but yeah I was just going to pick
up on what Sonia and Anna said and uh
councilor Brenton we are going to work
on putting emotion to full Council I
think it's something that we've really
very much need to scrutinize how Canty
is operating
um in this because it doesn't appear to
be acting
um in good faith having told that the
link center users that the proposal was
withdrawn to then extend the
consultation uh telling two different
groups of people different amounts of
information
doesn't doesn't help get to the right
decision for everybody it doesn't help
the district council know what the
impacts are going to be for its
residents and so we really have to do
that role of their critical friend and
say on this you're not even doing the
process right how can you get to the
right decision
um hack to move on to the next agenda
item
so action list pages eight
137 Southwest water that's still ongoing
responses to the questions
um a couple of report from the Dentistry
team to be chased up I was um I was
going to bring this up later I might as
well bring up now I've been talking to
councilor John patrinos the vice chair
of
the committee and North Devon Council
the equivalent of our committee here has
got a different name I think it's policy
review
he he's Keen for us to have some joint
meetings and one of those was based on
Dentistry so that was something when we
come to the forward plan whether we
could work that out with North Devon
Council if people were keen and also
agriculture is obviously towards and
North Devon is quite an overlap in the
both of those areas and that would be
something I'd be suggesting later on
um
oh just to say you don't need to stay
for the rest of the meeting the public
if you didn't want to but it's up to you
it's
just because it's not officially an
agenda item we can't have any debates as
such
um
number 192 right to MP raise concerns
regarding lack of clarity and the delay
to the hospital program we
haven't heard back and I understand
Karen sent another email chasing and we
still haven't heard back is that right
his chair and it was also sent to um
Celine sax BMP for North Devon and I
don't think we had a response from her
either
yeah thank you um I thank you
um I did get the um slides from Stacy
and I hope you'll thank her for me on
that on her what I already have
um but it did seem to me even in this
the slides that I got because I wasn't
the meeting where we had the
presentation that they're very very
ambiguous and they don't really clarify
any of the points that we were worried
about
um I also wonder whether the resignation
of Suzanne Tracy the CEO of
um our DNE and University Hospitals
trust whether that's having any effect
on the program and what's happening I
think to for the CEO to resign is
obviously quite a big thing for any
organization and it does worry me that
you haven't had any words since about
what is going on and how much of a
budget we still don't know as Cheryl
pointed out in her last how much of a
budget we've got for the improvements of
the
um of the north Devon hospital and we
don't have a time scale so you know
what's going on here I do think it does
indicate there's some kind of
um
Hiatus in what's happening down at the
Rd University trust and that we should
have more information about how it
affects our Hospital up here
I'm happy to if we add on into that then
with the chasing of answers and the
impact of the resignation of the CEO
Suzanne Tracy if people are happy yeah
um thank you chair um
thank you
um 100 oh that's got the same number
um looking into reorganizing the police
bite size training which at the last
meet I mentioned we had
I think
um four years ago whenever it was um but
unfortunately they've responded saying
that there's not currently the resource
to put together a program for that which
is a bit of a shame because I found that
really helpful as a new counselor
um at the beginning of the previous
Council so I didn't know if what we want
to do in terms of that if they haven't
got the capacity to provide it I'm not
sure what we can do
so yeah we did we did request it and
they said they can't can't offer it
unfortunately well care isn't it true
that at the full council meeting of the
new Council and the AGM
the police officer we had there
um who I've got his name here assured us
that they wanted to do everything they
could I see people in modeling to
support the District Council in its
liaison with the police and to encourage
us to get involved and be supportive of
them and I think this is a two-way
street actually and if they want us to
support them and encourage their local
community to be supportive then they've
got to support us and I think this is
quite a small thing if this program's
already in situ
and it's already been
um made up and is available I really
don't think that's a very good excuse
for not being able to provide it for the
rest of the council and as I was
somebody who didn't see it anyway
because I wasn't on scrutiny then I do
think that we should write back and say
well actually we feel there's a real
need for this especially as there's so
much worries about policing in Devon
generally and I won't say anything about
that because I'll get somebody saying oh
you know blah blah but um but it is a
fact that there's some issues on Devon
County policing that the community
people I talk to Industry are really
worried about so I think that the idea
that the police aren't prepared to let
us sit in on this um this scheme and
have these bite-sized bits of
information from them it's ludicrous I
really do think English and I think we
should go back and say it and look you
know our community is concerned about
what's happening with policing in our
area and we feel it's essential that we
have this yeah we can and the next
meeting we have will be the community
safety Partnerships and that's something
that we compare
because like you say they're saying they
want our support but we're requesting to
get support from them and we're not able
to because they're not providing it so
it's something that we can definitely
and if we have him in front of us in
person it'll be a lot easier to put that
across as well I think it sure will
um
I think that was all of the
action list
um
Declaration of Interest members of
Interest should refer to the agenda item
and describe the nature of their
interest in the item is considered
considered agreement of agenda items
part one and two there's no part two so
that's easy
urgent matters brought forward with the
permission of the chair
um I would just bring something up that
I'm very passionate about and that's the
mobile libraries across the whole of
Devon I spoke on radio Devon this
morning for the first time with Michael
Rosen the children's author
um I just think it will really affect
especially torridge and I did say as the
tourist District councilor
it really will have a massive impact
here and in North Devon
um and there are a few
statistics so in storage we've got the
third lowest workplace earnings in the
UK out of 370. we've got the second
lowest adult social Mobility rate in
England and we've got the third highest
population on Universal Credit across
all the southwest councils and I feel
like these types of
they're not it's been completely
disregarded by Devon County Council and
people can sit and Exeter and make these
decisions without really understanding
the impacts
um on people on real people that live in
in torch especially but obviously the
whole of Devon
um so if people are able to sign a
petition am I allowed to say this sign
the petition and share the campaign and
I can send out paper petitions as well
to people because not everyone's got
internet access
then that would be appreciated yeah
councilor Smith
thank you chair
um I'd just like to remind councilors
the impact that was felt in great
Torrington when we lost the the library
van that we've got it was uh it was
subject to an arson attack last summer
and the impact in the local Villages was
was very very severe so there is a
classic example of how the area
suffers from lack of Library rounds I
mean I wouldn't recommend we go around
um
repeating that experiment and it wasn't
an experiment but it was it was the
impact of that is I think we have to
take and take into account thank you
Jack and also
um through coved the mobile Library fans
kept going they offered the service and
they put the books in the bags for
people and that if if we didn't have
that like if we were to go hopefully
we'd never do if we went through
something like that again they really
provided such an amazing service for our
most vulnerable people
I just think it's so important and I
really hope that this that Devon County
Council will make a u-turn on it it's
been called in for scrutiny and the
meetings at the end of September
Council Smith if I may just also say
it's it's not just a matter of Finance
it is the social impact of these uh
these Vans they go around and often it's
the only contact outside the village
that some people have elderly people who
can't uh who can't transport themselves
around so it has a huge social impact I
think
um accountants who who look at it with a
pointy pencil
um are losing half the plot you know
it's not all about Finance I realize
Finance is critical but I think they
need to look beyond that and look at the
social impact
yeah and I let looked at some other
counties across
across England and in Cambridgeshire
they work in partnership with different
people so they're providing not just
books but like
we've got hearing aid batteries hearing
support they sell stamps and reading
glasses and they provide a council
inquiry service and people can pay their
account Council bills Etc on the library
set the library ban so I think there's
ways that we could develop the service
which would benefit our rural
communities and they there was also a
University study which found that
England's libraries generate the
equivalent of 3.4 billion pounds and
that's the value of our libraries and
the mobile libraries in Cambridgeshire
alone they've thought they um
the study said that that created a value
of 300 000 pounds that's just the mobile
Library service so I think some of these
things are being forgotten by our County
councilors making those decisions
anyway let me get one yeah
um with your permission um chair could I
bring up the subject of the closure of
ticket officers
right well I think everybody knows about
the closure of Railway ticket offices
and of course it doesn't affect us in in
North Devon and courage very much
because our ticket office has already
closed but we do have Exeter and I do
feel this is a very detrimental step for
anybody who wants to travel most people
who travel on the trains in this area do
so because they probably haven't got a
car or they if they have they don't want
to do that long journey and that
includes older people like me and people
who have disabilities of any kind people
who are eyesight problems and to close
ticket offices that are already existing
is such an adverse step for anybody who
has a problem that is and isn't
absolutely a hundred percent
top-notch healthy I've got eyesight
problems I dread when I can't use the
ticket machines I just cannot use them
so how do I get on when I want to go to
get a ticket from Exeter or somewhere I
I can manage to get a ticket my husband
will get me a ticket down to Barnstable
but then I really do need to take your
office and sometimes lots of Journeys
are complicated and you need to make
inquiries about how you're going to get
from me to be there's a huge campaign at
the moment also petitions on the
internet that for us to save the ticket
offices of more major and sub major
stations because they do a great service
for the people especially in rural areas
who would be stranded and isolated if
they didn't have a good train service so
I would urge that we actually make some
kind of
a proposal to torridge as well that we
actually support the campaign to prevent
the closure of any more ticket offices I
know that most people I know who use the
train and go from Barnstable have found
it terrible that they closed Barnstaple
office there used to be a great guy
there who knew everything about all the
trains in this country practically and I
used to go up regularly to London for
some committee meetings and I wouldn't
have been able to go if I he wasn't
there because I couldn't manage to
Fathom the ticket machine or even the
brochures with the timetables myself
so you know it's stopping people from
having access to other parts of the
country and access to our rail service
which is a much Greener initiative
anyway so please
this initiative to support the ticket
offices and prevent their closure
councilor Smith thank you I just like to
add to that a lot of the people that you
smartphones
the internet elderly people
in the past
and by
do that
I'm getting
important to take
people do
either
[Music]
mobile libraries and the linked centers
and affecting the most vulnerable in our
society as well and people without the
access to Internet and transport and all
of these types of things that are
affecting people especially
have
to
item eight
program delivery
um you're probably thinking why is Sean
speaking to uh for those who haven't met
there are a couple of counselors in the
room I've met I'm Sean Carney I'm the
head of Community Place here at torridge
but I also have another role and I'm the
co-chief executive of North Devon plus
um next slide please Tom so we I'll go
through a few slides which will very
quickly outline what North Devon plus is
and then we go over to the interesting
bit and Louise will tell you because
Louise is the person at the coal face
um Louise will tell you actually the
impact about the impact that the
business has on local community
so
business was set up in 2008 it's an
economic development business and it was
brought together because there was lots
of business support agencies out there
in the environment and it's quite
confusing for people you had North Devon
Enterprise agency hoping and assisting
small businesses he had North Devon
marketing Bureau predominantly focusing
on tourism businesses locally and he had
North Devon and Expo regeneration
company which was slightly working with
the third sector at that time but also
delivering things that was all about
that were all about sort of improving
the local economy area
both north Devon and torridge at that
time thought this is this is quite a
confusing environment the business
community of telling us that was the
case and so things were rationalized and
it was all brought under one umbrella
and the company was set up called North
Devon Plus
it's owned by North Devon and Torres
District Council 50 50 and that's why uh
I'm the co-chief executive with the
chief executive of North Devon Council
uh Ken miles
it's a not-for-profit company so we we
generally we always offer excellent
value for money and whatever money is
made from any projects or programs that
we run has accumulated and fused for a
future projects and programs that are
intended to benefit the future fortunes
of people in the area and we focus on
regeneration and Business Development
Across Northern Devon but we have
delivered projects across the region and
an example of that would be a project
that we ran for the lap delivering grant
funding right the way up as far as
gloucestershire and down to the Arts of
silly uh next slide please Tom so this
is the board it's it's a it's a company
limited by guarantee it's chaired by
Alan Dykes who's from TDK Lambda so
there are there is a private sector
element to the board to give us that
sort of business knowledge but as you
can see that most of the makeup is
of local Authority either employees
myself and Ken miles from north Devon
um and uh four councilors so you've got
cancer in room from North Devon
councilor Malcolm price from North Devon
Council Ken James from torridge and
councilor bushby from turidge and
there's your private sector maps at the
bottom Allen who I've mentioned before
Tim Jones he's chairman of the Senator's
Business Council and Mike Matthews is
the managing director of lineal software
Solutions and that gives us quite a nice
balance in that it retains control of
the organization from a public sector
perspective so that we're delivering
services for our public but we have that
private sector injection of business now
so if you like and that intelligence
that they bring to the board next slide
please
so this just gives you a bit of a flavor
of how the business is set up staff wise
again I can keep mentioning myself as uh
so you'll get used to that
there's me and Ken at the top there
um Louise in the box below now Louise
runs the business on a day-to-day basis
Louise is our program delivery manager
and she sort of oversees all of the
operations of the business
finance is the support is provided by
tourist District Council so they've got
the two guys that are listed in there
are actually employees at origin not
employed by the business
uh we subcontract some of some of our
work because there's that much work to
do and it's difficult to find Qualified
people to do it and actually we need the
flexibility of being able to uh work
with people that
um we can pick up and put down again and
that works for them too so so that we're
buying that expertise from some
Freelancers that are listed there and
you've got sort of four key employees
underneath their Vicky price as a
program delivery officer Graham Walcott
is a program delivery business officer
Graham Works predominantly on the future
foreign resilience program another
pharma-related initiatives that business
runs uh the program delivery business
officer Stephen Taylor Jones the Steven
some more uh generalist business advisor
and has helped to run some of the
projects that Louise will talk about in
a minute but business boost being one
that toridge actually funded
um and so he does that and then you've
got Vicky feather who who sits beneath
it all making it all happen and pulling
it all together she and Vicky you will
become very familiar with this cancerous
because she organized she runs the um or
administers the councilor Grant scheme
for us now we used to have an in-house
officer a torch to do that actually it's
worked out very effective having Vicky
do this and North Devon plus his support
in running that program uh next slide
please Tom so that's it in a nutshell I
mean I've touched on my knees things so
I won't labor it you'll get into the
interesting bit now just to reiterate
it's a company that we own as a council
um it's not for profit it's it's an
excellent partnership between public and
private although we have the majority
shareholding so we have that control
we we excel in delivering business
support and I think locally on patch
that is what the business is most known
for and most respected for although
there's some huge project and delivery
management management delivery expertise
put in there and I think actually when
you look at huge Grant programs there
isn't anybody who knows more than the
staff at North Devon plus about how to
deliver a program of Grants
across a given geography
um
agricultural support I think is becoming
something that we
we've excelled in recently in in recent
years but it's something that's going to
be a Development Area for the future and
and also we've got a great business
intelligence so we've got access to lots
of statistical information we've got
research expertise in in some of our
contracted support through John Vernon
and so we help the councils actually
with bid writing and strategic support
so so that's me just to introduce the
business over to Louise who can talk to
you about actually what that means and
how that is delivered across the patch
Club
thanks very much Shauna thank you
everybody for allowing me to come and
speak to you today
um so what I'd like to do is to maybe
just run through some of the programs
that we've worked on and some of the
programs we're about to start working on
now just so to give you an idea of what
we're doing to support businesses in the
local area so when I was putting this
together I'm aware that obviously done
probably some new councilors in the room
that aren't so aware of North Devon plus
so I wanted just to do a little bit of
an overview to look back at what we've
achieved so far and surprised me really
in terms of the stats given that we're
quite a small and close team so looking
back since 2015 we've supported over 4
000 small businesses across Northern
Devon and that's across the north Devon
and torridge patch we set up we've
managed and delivered Grant investment
programs and we've managed to pull in
funding externally in excess of over 11
million pounds to local businesses so
that will include previous programs like
the leader program that some of you may
have been aware of
some of these are Legacy programs now
that were sort of financed by the
European Union
and through the programs that we've run
through either the business support or
the grant development programs we've
managed to assist businesses to create
over 600 jobs
next slide please Tom
so the the most critical area to the
business or the main part of the
business is the impartial business
support that we provide to local
businesses as Sean said through uh
Stephen Taylor Jones who's our generous
business support advisor
we help people to look at considering
starting a business what they need to
get up and running and we've done that
through some of the programs up there
we've got the startup and grow business
that we ran we often bid into Devon
County Council for business support
projects across the area so we run
successfully for a couple of years the
growth support program with DCC
just at the tail end of the European
Union funding we also ran a small
program at DCC called the EU transition
program and that was to Gear Up
businesses for some of the changes that
were coming in terms of 12 trading
across the European borders
business boost was something that we
started at the tail end of the
additional restrictions grants the staff
were really instrumental in helping
administer the additional restriction
grants across torridge
um and it was felt by the councilors at
that time that we wanted to leave a
little bit of Legacy there to help
businesses to restart and get back on
their feet to look at diversifying
so about a year and a half ago we
started up the business boost program
which was really really successful and I
think one of the reasons it was so
successful is because it was more
flexible than some of the EU programs
that we ran in the past so businesses
could dip in and out when it suited them
they didn't have to sign up for a
minimal amount of hours of support and
basically they could come and talk to us
at any point in time about what they
needed when they needed it
the Devon County Council growth Hub
services for all was a follow-on from
the growth support program with the last
elements of European funding just coming
through we delivered a two-year program
with the growth Hub called Thrive and
that was very much about around
looking at diversifying looking at
business growth looking at investment in
your business
and also just coming out of covid it was
the first time we kind of was a slightly
different project for us wasn't it Sean
we were involved in the Kickstart scheme
which some of you may or may not have
been aware of the DWP department for
work and pensions at the time wanted to
give young people more of an opportunity
to try and get back into work
um so we work really actively with local
job center plus across torridge and
North Devon to actually help work with
small businesses to generate employment
placements which hopefully would lead on
to permanent jobs
um we had we ran an excellent scheme
actually it was the first time we've
done that sort of work in quite a long
time and it was really really successful
I think we helped over 66 young people
get into placements and I think about 80
of them at the six month Mark was still
employed with their employers which was
great for us um
I know particularly over this side we
work with Move Free that created a lot
of placements for young people and we
also work with Atlas packaging as was at
the time to create quite a lot of
employment opportunities for them there
next slide please Tom
so in terms of Quant investment programs
what we generally do is we work with the
both local authorities and we will keep
our eyes peeled for any Grant investment
or monies coming through either through
the EU as Wars through Devon County
Council through broader organizations
and we will bid in to those programs to
make sure that we can bring Grant
investment into the area
then what we will do is we will work
with people applying we will take them
through the application process we will
work on the assessments we will issue
the funding agreements and then our
offices will work with the businesses to
help them project manage and deliver
that successfully so that just gives you
a bit of a flavor up there for some of
the things that we've done leader five
was a major program for us that was sort
of Community Based and also we helped a
lot and supported a lot of agricultural
businesses
unlocking business investment was for
slightly larger businesses that was a
big round of EU funding where we were
helping them with research and
development
the additional restrictions grants we
did three rounds I think it was Sean
wasn't it we we did for that
we also approached Devon County Council
as part of a Consortium when the
Community Renewal pilot started and we
put together again a grant support
program to try and help people in the
local area which we ran where the
company called Dr down in West Devon and
also business information point so we
were actively part of the Community
Renewal pilot which has led on to the UK
shared Prosperity funding if people are
aware of that now
um
we also do the counselor grants as some
of you may be aware of Vicky feathers
really proactive in helping with that
um in terms of positive better news on
that we've got some nice feedback from
Finance last year I think with with
Vicky's politeching of everybody to
spend their counselor grants
um it was one of the lowest residual
budgets I think we had left in the pot
wasn't it
um but also what we try and offer is an
added value to the Council of Grants is
we've got some really good intelligence
about other small grants coming through
whether it be sort of community social
grants and things like that so when
counselors are looking at their
counselor grants if they're also looking
for that organization or that um
that partnership really if you like to
add value or perhaps the councilor
grants can't fund the projects that you
want to look at Vicky is able to use our
internal database and resources to look
at any other funding opportunities that
you might want to be aware of and might
want to complement those projects with
and lastly the rural England Prosperity
fund
we didn't actually know this was coming
at one point did we
the UK shared Prosperity fund was
announced and then off the back of that
very quickly there was an extra Grant
attached to that for rural areas called
rural England Prosperity fund
we're actually working on the prospectus
for that at the moment and I'm hoping
that probably will be out in the next
two to three weeks but again there will
be grants of between
uh well probably I'm trying to think now
two and a half thousand up to 25 000 for
the Royal England Prosperity fund across
three key themes
so the theme's word dictated really by
central government and also the economic
development officers work quite closely
at Tories to put a plan together as to
what areas they wanted to focus on so
the rural England Prosperity will fund
will fund Nets area projects they will
help with Farm diversification and they
will also help with small and Community
businesses
really really
hot and it really needs to be audited by
government departments so your processes
have to be fixed run properly your
documents kept properly and everything
has to be shape-shaped and that for for
both local authorities I think is where
North Devon plus has come into its own
in designing these systems and then
properly administered administering them
so that we're compliant as two local
authorities on the other end and it it
just adds so much value and I think the
other thing to be interesting Louise is
if you talked about leader five for
instance leader five Where it All Began
really for for for the modern iteration
of North Devon plus it it perhaps scaled
says how what size were we talking about
here what was the leader fund and then
what was the leverage that that brought
to the area and you'll see that this is
huge numbers that North Devon plus has
been looking after for us yeah I mean in
terms of League defined that was a big
EU program and probably significantly
larger than even the UK share price of
fund is at the moment I mean that came
in at 2.3 million we were able to
leverage much funding out of that and we
created over 80 jobs with that program
um probably supported in the region of
about 120 businesses I think at the time
yeah I was just wondering about the um
Royal England Prosperity fancy when will
people be able to apply for those grants
so hopefully we we would like to release
the prospectus in the next couple of
weeks we've had a little bit of a delay
because as Sean said a lot of these
things are quite Technical and we've had
some eligibility queries and some other
queries in the background that we wanted
to make sure that we got clear answers
from dluck on who are managing this
before we actually released it and got
up and running with it but hopefully in
the next couple of weeks is that is that
600 000 pounds available or how much is
it five
cops isn't it isn't it yeah I think it
would be 500 000 over two years
slide please Tom
um the other thing I really wanted to
talk about today which we are sort of
acutely aware that have quite a large
impact on our local area obviously
agriculture is one of our Bedrock
sectors
um we're again we um bid into Devon
County Council to run the future bombing
resilience project which we're running
at the moment for two years and that
takes us up to March 2025
uh We've helped around 60 Farm
businesses already since we started that
last November now
um the purpose of the future farming
resilience is to make sure that farm
businesses are still
um
well are environmentally sound but are
obviously able to trade and continue
one of the issues at the moment and one
of significant changes if you may or may
not be aware is the reduction in the
basic payment scheme that agriculture
receives and Farms receive
that's been scaled back over the next
six years that is going to have a
significant impact on the way that
farmers farm and the way that their
business models work
so at the moment our business advisors
are at the coal face with Farmers Graham
for example goes out and see Farmers on
a one-to-one basis he looks at their
business plan he looks at the impact of
the reduction of their business basic
payment scheme he helps them look for
Farm diversification opportunities to
make sure that they can still trade and
at the same time we are trying to
translate quite complicated government
initiatives through the RPA and defra
into understandable
language and simple ways performance to
move forward what they need now need to
do is to make sense of things like the
sustainable farming incentives that have
just come out there's rafts and rafts of
Standards the SFI document came out it
was you know 600 pages long
um and we need to really you know we
need to help busy Farmers translate what
that actually means for their business
on a day-to-day basis and for them to
make strategic decisions going forward
on how to safeguard their businesses and
where their efforts need to be and at
the moment for a lot of them it's just
understanding how they can move to more
sustainable farming incentives but at
the same time making sure that they can
still Farm in the way that they have
done they can still keep animals they
can still put them out to graze but they
can do that with a mixture of
environmental awareness as well
alongside that
until next slide please
um how am I doing for time I don't want
to overrun apologists
um as Sean alluded to earlier as one of
the things that we do to support
business we also offer some support
services to the local authorities and
the economic development teams so myself
and Dr John Vernon who some of you may
or may not know
um
he is instrumental really in providing
sort of data and strategic analysis
John's been quite instrumental hasn't he
shown in writing the tourism strategy
previously for both local authorities
he's working with the economic
development officers at the moment on
the data side of the new economic
development plan we've helped with
things like the bid for the northern
Borough Center
so again whenever we feel that there are
skills that we can put out to support
the local authorities we talk to Ken and
Sean our weekly strategic meetings and
we will give help and support where
that's required I don't know if there's
anything you want to add to that a bit
sure
it's a really handy having the
organization from a local Authority
perspective so take off my North Devon
plus hat and put on my torrage one
um we haven't always got the enough
resource to drive the economy the area
forward within our own resources and
having North Devon plus and that
expertise that's there to be able to say
okay our Economic Development teams can
go so far can you provide us with this
additional
intelligence or services and buy those
in so that we're not paying somebody all
the time we're just buying what we need
when we need from the organization it's
been fantastic and I think sometimes as
well having that that perhaps that
degree of separation from local
authority to that sort of slightly arms
length company helps provide a bit of
credibility when we're we're dealing
with external agencies as well they sort
of think that you know you set a company
it's been running since 2008 it's
delivered all these things you obviously
know what you're doing and so the out
from the um from the company has been
valued by well everybody I can't think
of anything that's been produced that
people have sent back moving forward I
think
you're going to be invaluable as an
organization and delivering anything
that comes from the Future Energy
opportunities for the area the the
ecosystem business ecosystem that's um
emerging around Apple door and the
Innovation Center that we're delivering
down there as a council and North Devon
plus and their business support services
are going to be really really helpful
for us in pushing all of that forward I
think I'm kind of interest to say thank
you next slide please Tom
um I think I've pretty much been over
this already so I won't sort of
reiterate too much and one thing I've
I've just popped some leaflets around
for you this morning
um the business boost scheme is live
that's got funding through the UK shared
Prosperity fund
um so we will be supporting 190
businesses or one-to-one Support over
the next two years we will be able to
offer small grants of up to fifteen
hundred pounds to up to 98 businesses
um the pot for that is reasonably
limited so it will be a competitive
process for that this time but we will
guide businesses through it and help
them where we can and signposts onto
other programs where they may not be
eligible
um we are going to be doing a
sustainability plan with at least 90 of
those businesses to help them become
more sustainable we're aiming to create
11 new jobs and the creation of five new
businesses
Royal England Prosperity fund I think
I've already touched on
um those are the three priorities the
investment priorities that we will be
putting out shortly and the team will
continue to work on the councilor grants
and undertake the grant searches thanks
Tom
oh no I didn't sorry I beg your pardon
do you wanna
um through the UK share Prosperity fund
unfortunately
um central government still to be fairly
hung up on the same definitions that we
used to use under EU funding so to be
able to work with pre-starts on new
startup businesses basically the caveat
is that they've got have been trading
for a set amount of time or they've got
a unique tax reference number or
company's house number now
um I spoke to this smt team a couple of
weeks ago because I said look we really
want to help pre-start and start up
businesses but the um the output
definitions and the conditions by which
we have to adhere to under this don't
actually allow us to do that unless
we're actually pushing small pre-start
businesses to register for their unique
tax reference with hmrc and we didn't
want to do that really it's not for us
to be pushing them towards that remit
until they're ready so
um we had a strategic meeting didn't we
and we discussed pre-stop provision so
what we're going to do is is for those
people that that's not appropriate for
we're invest reinvesting some of the
north Devon's we've done not seven plus
is money through both local authorities
to be able to run a self-funded startup
program to make sure that we can still
have that dialogue and that conversation
with those people still thinking about
starting a business and only just really
getting ready to start up thanks Sean
thanks Tom
this last slide really is just to really
give an overview is some of the sectors
that we have or we continue to work with
um and I think Tom that's it was that q
a yeah that's me I hope I haven't
overrun apologies
thank you that was that was really
really good um councilor Buck thank you
chair Louise that was really interesting
you're obviously a very busy
organization that's growing over the
years where does all your money come
from
so in terms of our funding we get core
funding from both local authorities
which is 20 000 pounds per year the rest
of the funding is all funding that we
bid for uh on a competitive basis so we
will We I'm continuously much to my joy
bid writing and looking to to pull in
funding for for the organization to be
able to deliver and develop some of
these Services thank you
is to give us a context if we went back
into the the should we call it the
pre-austerity years
um you would have found that North Devon
Council was putting in somewhere north
of 250 000 pounds a year and torrich is
putting in about 130 000 pounds a year
into the core of North Devon plus and at
that time North Devon Plus at one point
had more than 50 people on the books
um so you can see how the organization
was scaled back because of austerity
because we could you know there's two
local authorities you could no longer
afford to to provide that core support
to an external organization so it's
paired back and concentrated right on
its specialism used to be involved in
lots of different projects and programs
across a whole Arena of things it's come
right back to its core now and that the
guys are really effective at making it
pay for itself on a 40 Grand between two
local authorities core income so it's a
it is it's been quite successful
cancer
Smith um thank you for a very
interesting uh presentation there do you
deal at all with the charitable
organizations or is it purely business
startups
so through our business support we do
offer support to Charities and we offer
support to CICS
and and social Enterprises in effect if
you like
um the only time we don't do that is if
we're Bound by Grant rules that
determine that we can't do that but
certainly for the uks PF program that
I've circulated that's a lovely thing
I'll speak to you about that later
support okay no problem
thank you sir
and I do support absolutely uh local
agriculture
um Community it doesn't present the
biggest proportion of this community
it's in a minority in the whole of the
country and in this community so there's
lots of other areas that also need
support and you know the link center is
a case in point and it's not getting any
support and I find that horribly ironic
and very disappointing my question is
about
help for local Eco Industries for
instance a lot of people are putting
solar panels on their roofs now and heat
pumps but in a a community like this
where we do despite all your hard work
and efforts we still have one of the
lowest waged communities in the country
and
how much support are you giving or able
to give to small
companies that want to
dive into the solar panel or the heat
pump Industries because particularly
heat pumps they're really out of the
price of most local people who already
are paying a huge mortgage or a massive
rent but know that if only they had a
heat pump they would benefit on the long
in the long run in their energy bills
but they just can't afford to buy one
yeah thank you so one of the um one of
the priority initiatives through the
Royal Enterprise
sorry the rural England Prosperity fund
is um Net Zero so one of the bits in the
prospectus will be to provide grants to
small businesses to help them on their
Journey towards achieving Net Zero but
what we're also mindful of is the fact
that we will need to support businesses
probably to get some sort of energy
order in an independent energy audit
I've been talking to 361 for example
I'm saying to them we've got a small
ground pot we need to make sure that
that goes as far as it it can and in the
right areas
so one thing we will be doing as part of
the prospectus if I I've liaised with
them on some of the key questions that
we need to get business thinking about
in terms of wanting to get grants to do
this stuff and one of the key things
that needs to happen is an independent
energy assessment for them to say
for example we might get lots of
businesses coming in saying oh we want
solar panels that's definitely the way
forward but actually if you had an
independent energy assessment what that
might tell you is it's much better for
you to change to a set energy tariff or
it's much better to look at a different
type of technology so we will be
offering our first probably first
dedicated part of grant money Sean
really is an internet zero this one so
it'd be interesting to watch how that
develops really and how many businesses
that we're able to support and what
savings they can make as a result thank
you for that but actually I don't think
you I I misled you about my question I
want to know what you're doing to
support the people who are making these
things we've we went into solar panels
and we had to go to South Devon for it
because there didn't seem to be anybody
at the time supplying solar panels in
this area so
um what sort of initiatives have we got
for the producing our own companies that
would produce either solar panels or
heat pumps in the local area I mean what
we haven't got at the moment is we
haven't got a huge a huge access to
companies things like Angel investment
and I know it's one of the things that
the economic development officers are
looking at as part of the UK share
Prosperity obviously we can only work
within the narrow parameters of the
grants that we've got to offer but I
would hope that we can try and get the
message out and hopefully through the
local councils get the message out as
clearly as possible that there is
business support for startup businesses
to grow and develop and to do that but
you're right maybe we need to look at
some really clear messaging around Net
Zero specifically
councilor Thomas I'm just picking up on
the the funding if I understood rightly
I think you're saying that we've we've
now got about 10 percent of the core
funding that you had at the startup and
you mentioned you've helped 4 000
businesses since 2005. so I'm just
curious
how much of that 4 000 was in the first
few years compared with what you're
doing now
well that
has been spread across those those years
I mean the organization as it was prior
to my time but but what I've counted is
from leader five onwards so those have
been all of the main Grant programs that
have been open for central government
that we've managed to be successful to
bid in to to deliver back out so the
scale of support hasn't reduced because
of the core funding per se if that makes
sense so you're doing as much with a lot
with less yes
and doing a range of different things
different things so when when there was
going to call funding the reach of the
businesses
in core around this sense
um
Assurance programs training programs
like others
councilor craigie
yeah yeah I wanted to ask about um
social Enterprise and particularly I'm
thinking of the community ownership fund
that obviously central government is
trying to provide a large sum of money
for areas to keep things of community
assets but obviously with the
expectation that there's going to be
some sort of income generation from that
and obviously that's probably a
different sort of mindset to most most
Community groups have got so what sort
of support
is are you able to sort of help with
those groups or support those groups to
develop those sort of ideas to access
that funding
yeah I mean through our general business
support those organizations could come
in and talk to us about the application
what we can't do is obviously write the
application for them because we only
have limited resources but what we can
do is through our general business
support if they want to come in and talk
to us they will have to supply things
like their accounts they'll have to
supply probably a marketing plan A
business plan all of those I've looked
at the fund it's quite demanding in
terms of what people will need to
produce so I think you're right it will
be quite new to a lot of those
organizations so through our general
business support they can get come in to
get support for that but as I say I
suppose the dividing line comes between
us offering that support versus us being
able to actually write the application
because we just don't have the resource
to be able to do that
I mean are you able to help them say
with developing those marketing plans
and business plan yes absolutely that's
at the core of the service you know we
can we
can we can review it
um but we're either starting from
scratch or we we work in revisiting
basically yeah
um any other questions
it seems unlikely considering that I get
an impression from your talk that
there's quite a lot of Europe in some of
these grandsons
um some of these Grant applications uh
particularly the ones coming from the
central government but do you do any
support for online businesses because I
know there's a lot of small online
businesses all over the place and and in
our area so what sort of support can you
give them especially if they might not
be when I I wouldn't say amateurish but
you know they aren't conventionally
business-like
yeah and again this this has fallen into
the remit of probably some of the Thrive
programs through the growth business
support program and again through the um
business boost program
um we work with businesses uh to look at
their marketing strategy we will bring
in external trainers if necessary to
help with things like SEO optimization
you know all of the the web-based stuff
um even adding sort of e-commerce to the
website and understanding what impact
that might have on the business looking
at their price their promotion in
relation to that we sometimes we dealt
actually a lot with businesses coming
out of covert that had obviously changed
their operating models you know you had
things like some of the restaurants
offering takeaway Services Etc just as
an example
and what we saw quite a lot when
continuing to see is that
those businesses of some of them have
chosen to con continue with that
Diversified model
um so you're right there have been a lot
of businesses that probably weren't um
online focused as much potentially as
they are now some of them have decided
to drop their overheads and go online
completely
um others are looking at a mix of
business and as I say we we offer
support with the website stuff the
social media training development around
that and just making sure that people
are up to date with sort of new industry
um Trends if you like that are coming
through and the way particularly things
like tourism businesses they really need
to be ahead of the game though in making
sure that they can get that message out
to get Keen repeat business from
customers
and now can I ask just one last stupid
question
um
do you have any sort of input into the
situation
such as there is in Biddeford where
really quite important retail retail
outlets like super drug completely
withdraw
from the town
was there any consultation between you
and them or could you have given them
some kind of incentive to stay
but although it didn't obviously didn't
happen but could you make done any help
there because I mean Biddeford is
suffering from you know pulling out of
retail people
um obviously they're not start-up
businesses they're the opposite they've
been often trading for many many years
but they decided that Biddeford is not
worth staying in because presumably the
poor Football under a poor economy so is
there anything you can do to help with
that because I think that is a big issue
of a bit of a particularly we it
slightly Falls outside of our remit I
probably asked Sean to pick this one up
because this is something that probably
Falls more within the remit of the
economic development offices through
things like future High streaks and
various of initiatives yeah yeah 100
years I said it was stupid no it's not
stupid at all it's a matter of scale
here I think if we if we're talking
about a small business in town small
retail outlet that wanted business to
Pro support and advice to see whether it
was viable we can provide those Services
through some of the programs at times
something of scale like you know a
national chain like your reference they
make their business decisions elsewhere
those decisions are that they're made
you know so we have an economic
development team and and currently the
council funds here Economic Development
officer and you've got a town center
project officer and they're working with
town councils and local Partners to
deliver because sort of town Improvement
plans and regeneration strategies and I
think that's where that sort of activity
goes now do we know sometimes that
someone's going to leave town no if we
fight the council will find out the same
time as everybody else they don't always
consult with us some will give us a a
forewarning of their their strategy if
you like their business strategy and you
can work with them rarely the incentives
on the scale that we could provide would
entice them to stay they tend to be
operated on a much higher level than
that right okay thanks
sorry this might be a silly question as
well but um we were having a quick chat
before the meeting actually about the
Penny Market would things are you able
to work with councils I mean obviously
it says business yeah so yeah one would
argue that
the council is a business or
um so are you able to to work with the
Penny Market Committee to come up with
some ideas and help us figure out what
we're going to be what we can do with
the hall up there
again
I suppose the remit is is slightly
outside we could work with the
individual Traders within the market
that would be within our remit but I
think in terms of the developments again
of the pioneer Market it's probably
within Chris's remit in terms of the
economic development teams and then
pulling any investment in and I think
probably looking at some stuff under UK
SPF for that yeah yeah so I think I
think okay so Hawkins will have to pick
that discussion up from a torrage aspect
rather than not doing this one
but just us then uh they they they're
all individual traders in the Penny
Market Committee uh in the Penny Market
uh but they've also set up a Cooperative
oh okay uh so potentially I from what
you should say The Cooperative could
make use of uh absolutely brilliant
um I was just going to ask what's the
best way for people to contact you about
because we're obviously going to spread
the word as counselors how should we
tell them to contact you uh it's also
wondering where do the one-to-one
meetings take place and is there a
charge for any of the support that you
offer
um so in terms of oh God chat my glasses
oh yes there's something
so you've got some information on the
bottom of the fly there hopefully that
will take you to our website my polite
ask for today was going to be
um please talk to people in your local
communities be they people that are
interested in starting up those people
running businesses possibly Farmers um
please encourage them to come and talk
to us the easiest way to get in touch is
you can contact us at info North
devonplus.co.uk or you can call us on
01237-428-834
the one-to-one meetings whatever you've
got a specific location where they take
place and is there a charge for any of
the support that you offer no all of our
services are free because they are
funded at source through some of the
funding sources that I've spoken about
in terms of appointments um since covid
we've moved predominantly to on online
um appointments they are available face
to face if people want to make a
face-to-face meeting with a business
advisor but what we found is that
actually for most busy entrepreneurs and
small business owners they actually
prefer a quick video link and zoom call
but we can offer both
um we don't have a an office base as
such in terms of a a business center per
se we can offer appointments out of the
riverbank house premises and we can on
the North Devon side we tend to go meet
people at node as well if they want to
meet there
I think exception to that is is probably
the future Farm resilience consultations
where Graham's always he tells us every
week about the the depth of slurry that
he's been wading through so he's he's
actually he's actually out in the field
question
your phone number four two double eight
three five four I've got on here is that
correct you said three oh a four is on
main number five is obviously a
connecting number but
osc65 yeah that's not a problem okay
could we also offer the I know we did
this before um the Torrington work Hub
is a place oh yes
Stephen has been over and he's done a
couple of sessions where he's just gone
over to work in case there are drop-ins
um but if anybody specifically wants to
have a meeting over there as well yeah
for the Torrington area
excellent so I don't know if we've got
any recommendations or proposals as a
result obviously we will need to go out
and make people aware of this as best we
can
um whether we can put the slides in the
members bulletin and get things out on
social media and it's sort of our roles
to take it back to our parish councils
and our local communities to spread the
word and get people contacting you to
boost business and employment
opportunities Etc
I think we'd be really happy to bring
back
um
obviously the council is going to have
to report on the success of the rural
prosperity and share Prosperity fund
work and I think at some point maybe in
12 hours time something in the future
agenda and Louise can come back and tell
you about the effectiveness of what's
been delivered through those two
programs specifically for the council if
you're interested in a more slightly
more detailed report on that
yeah sounds good thank you thank you for
coming and thank you telling us it's
really useful
what's next
consideration of the forward plans the
next meeting we've got planned is the
community safety partnership which is
joint with North Devon Council led by
Toby Davies
and that's not until 12th of October
because I think there are issues of
linking it together with North Devon
Council and getting a date together
and that will be held at brinsworthy
yeah so North Devon are hosting that
this year so um yeah I think it will be
brainsworthy I might have had
okay and the one in November we've got
that so that would be quite soon after
just a few weeks after that one the
education employment and Storage
District with a focus on Harland and
wolf
and
pet truck and Biddeford College
those types of
um groups can I just ask on cycle three
the date's been changed from September
13th to October the 12th is that written
in stone because I'm going to be
overseas on the 12th of October
that is actually bolted down now I think
that is yeah is it based on um the chair
of the Community
Education my apologies Never Say Never
and also I didn't know if we could put
down I don't know a specific date but
look at whether we could get one on
agriculture and any touchments they each
find resilience I think it was around
four years ago we did it joint of North
Devon and invited in different groups
like The nfu and
various suburbs yeah
um the Exmore farming Network
yeah councilor craigie
I just wondered where where in our
future program can we put uh the thing
about the link center and the mental
health within torrage because I think it
goes sort of broader than just the link
center itself
um to the adult social social care that
Devin is providing in the Care Act
responsibilities that Devin perhaps not
living up to who do you propose that we
should bring in on that because
obviously we tried to get someone from
Devon County in and they refused so
um well I think we should also obviously
invite um GP practices now they have
their their social prescribers and
other
um
yeah reps who would try and sort of fill
in the gaps when it comes to Mental
Health Services and of course that
there's the Devon Mental Health Alliance
which is
uh five
National sized charities
which would be very good to hear from
them
what they are actually doing in the area
what they intend to do in the area and
so forth I think it's important
um have we started we haven't started
contacting anybody about the education
and employment one actually so we could
not yet we could move that one and put
that one in there is that but that's
still not going to be until November is
that too late or
I mean if that's the earliest available
then that's the earliest available but
uh
yeah I can I can leave move those
yeah I should do that because I feel
like that links into a lot of others not
just the link centers it's the whole
provision across different Services
isn't it
and we can we might know the outcome of
the mobile libraries as well then bring
that into councilor Thomas I'll just um
by canceling or postponing September
meeting to October we've got a 10-week
gap between this meeting and the next
one and then a three-week gap can we not
still have the September meeting
and have a meeting in October to do all
the Community Partnership because like
counselor Smith I'm not going to be
around in October so I won't be in that
one and I can't be on the first November
either so apologies
yeah I'm happy to have if we're able to
as a council type one in there's an
extraordinary meeting
for the 13th of September we had
originally had and yeah I think the
bookings is still in place so if we can
get people to come in at that notice but
we can try
and if if counselors want to email
suggestions of people to invite because
you might go away and think of people
who are more appropriate we can see
who's available
thank you
proposal there are various social
organizations that do support
um
various um Community people in this in
this area and support mental health
people
um and you know perhaps I'm thinking of
TBS because when I was working as a
volunteer project person there we did
support quite a lot of schemes to help
people who needed moderate support with
mental health issues and there was a lot
of expertise there actually most of it
actually coming from the people that
that were supposedly our clients but
there was a lot of expertise so I think
it would be quite a good idea to
possibly have people in like the ones we
just heard like um was it Anna Anna who
could come to a meeting and tell us in
more than three minutes
um about the details of what they feel
the issues are and how they can be
hopefully addressed and and then we
would have a really good platform to
approach the hospitals with you know
this is the thing I mean we do have this
over-the-top top-down sort of look at
things that actually the the real issues
and the Integrity of the situation is
with you so really I think if we could
invite obviously Anna possibly again if
she's willing to come again
and um and somebody people from TBS they
do a lot of
um help to support people and what they
did do when I was working there and um
and we can then do that kind of scrutiny
research to make sure that we've got a
really good case to say to to especially
our DNE look you know we we've got this
big case to support our Link Center and
we want you all to put into it to take
it to Devon County Council I'm just
wondering again about whether that link
with North Devon Council whether we
invite North Devon councilors alone for
me yeah because it's across the both
councils isn't it and that might have a
stronger case
even the two of us join together
councilor Smith I'd also like to add
Social Services to that social services
to that was my wife my late wife was
very influential with social services
and I know how much work she did with
with mental health so I would like to
add that counselor yeah because it's
very much in that sort of uh gap between
the social care Healthcare
um that these things go go awry yeah so
I think it is important that we get the
Devon NHS partnership for mental health
because obviously they deal with the
more severe end of hospitalization but
we do need the adult social care
um from County to be there because they
do have a duty of uh care after
hospitalization to prevent relapse and
so it's it it's a duty which is often
forgotten about because it's from a 1983
Act
so it's not necessarily fresh in
everyone's mind all the time and when we
understand that you know counties had it
difficult with getting social workers
and the like it's important that we make
sure that the social workers and the
healthcare are working together not in
opposition
so you have to first
and see who we can get together
yeah I'm happy too if you want to maybe
three councilor craigie I don't know
Council Hawkins
I suppose more than more than merrier
really yeah the more people you can have
selling their story that the better it
would be I was curious uh obviously
Devon County have sort of declined to
come and speak to us and we're going to
try and put them together
at the moment are we going to invite
them again we are going to invite them
as well to this next year you know
because you can't keep saying no and we
can let them know that it'll be
alongside other agencies as well
thank you so I think we need to make it
clear to people that we don't want
presentations from them maybe we have a
few main questions to give them in
advance and let them know that the other
people who will hopefully be attending
because we don't want it to go on for
four hours that's my worry when you
invite lots of different agencies in
that that issue would arise so we could
make it clear that we want it to be more
of a discussion between the groups
rather than individual presentations
so is that something that we can deal
with via email as counselors and put
forward make it quite succinct with our
questions and our concerns and hopefully
you get a good outcome and we can
publicize it as well can't we to invite
members of the public to come
okay good and so I think if we leave it
at that with the forward plan that it
leaves it we don't want to set up the
whole year because it leaves it flexible
like we've just done then
you know everyone happy
can I close the meeting oh
oh sorry exclusion of the public we
don't need to do that because there's no
part to
um
declare the meeting closed at 11 27
thank you